a lot of people think congress doesn't
do much of anything I am one of those
people but they're working hard for you
you know they just did they introduced a
bill I to
cut down on photoshopping I've models
in magazines yeah this is your
government working for you
it is called the truth in advertising
act and %uh let's get a excerpt from the
bill
an increasing amount academic evidence
linked exposure to such
altered images with emotional mental and
physical health issues
including eating disorders especially
among children and teenagers
there's a particular concern about the
marketing such images
to children and teenagers a
and of course you know we see this all
the time I magazine that lately there's
been a trend that celebrities that
release
the actual pictures are themselves I
think Lena Dunham is already started
this
we've got some photoshop images up
celebrities in case you're not sure
what's going on these magazines with
people to it is with you and we just
talked about when the
that Lindy to the left and that is her
airbrushed itself to the right
I mean without being too glib about the
thing that we just did before that she
doesn't look back you mean either one of
them but you can see clearly like to
create a lot of the latter alien this
going on
on that that picture to the right in its
you know clearly photoshopped and
cleaned up in all that arise look alien
ish
George Clooney they took some wrinkles
out and
here little more little more color guys
feel free to chat and where the 10
after way where at least before they
like or looks great in after-hours awful
enough money they took the salt pepper
how you're going to like that but
clearly
grab some changes adams apple to make a
more manly here whenever
lightly dark are a jerk it has eyebrows
to its which is later would have usually
Peter Gallagher
good idea but let you are there some
artist somewhere going we better dark in
his
adams apple meaning literally said we
need more contoured right hinge adams
apple
what is name would not be happy about
that who got the adams apple removed
percent Bruce Jenner without the added
that one more period
and we got the best possible picture we
could find a Katy Perry
and their yeah I mean look at to the
left you see a
somewhat human voice with some pores and
that she and and then they
what is this obsession with making a
really great alien it's very porcelain
doll
it's like I wanna see someone who looks
like they've never actually been in the
Sun
ever yeah I made and they sleep in with
your eyes are having a look at that
anyway let's go back late so
yeah I think it's a great bill actually
have been to really get the problem is a
my distrust of congress mean that like
way if it ever gets past
it will be toothless and nothing will
happen and
you know but then again cigarette
companies can advertise in all budget
places these be able advertise now
although sadly we have electronic
cigarette advertisements all over the
place that sure the time
yeah they can't take that away to I
don't share Yahoo I think the building a
far enough
reside in which people are funny people
aware hey
I wanna see like put more flaws in two
people
yeah make us feel better about ourselves
out dreams rather
yeah I would be nice really just like
ruin them
yeah I don't mean to be mean and a
saying like I wanna see Katy Perry
with like a big guy at and bad skin and
like
you know that having a horrible hair day
I wanna see that not only get started on
makeup I wanted them to actually create
that image
so what is the group for the people that
read these magazines and look at people
that are
there are already more beautiful than
the more richer than them and have all
the things that they don't have
and then on top of that they make them
look even better then they look normally
what was going on like psychologically
what do you think you're going all
I mean it it's creating the something to
aspire to
but is fictional me rather than it does
not exist in the universe yeah
and so well you're right because they're
starting to look later
you're starting to create a situation
where its literally unattainable
like these goals are unattainable and
that causes
perpetual and completely
complete failure it's always going to be
tell you there's no way to reach that's
enough
and it cause of all mental health issues
in eating disorders an awful things I
there's no reason why we need Kate Upton
to be my eye heard a
from a friend of a friend who was
working on that movie with Kate Upton
but they were he they were doing digital
Baxter
make her look like slightly skinnier in
the movie it's okay to be
gorgeous were you talking about Graham
why do we need skinny like nobody's like
other thing I know about Kate Upton is
how tiny she is yeah
and it's insane well I think there was
something web promo shot even have Hot
in Cleveland where they even
try to make very white look a little
slimmer than I i do.
but I really like sex her up because you
really have to sack the right trying to
master the body white yeah away from
here is a small group of people
and her that do that um but are we all
doing this in our own life too because
we all have that Instagram thing and we
can blur things and we can make
ourselves look Tanner
and all that so that is is that even
more perverse that regular people
I don't think so what's really minor the
weather let's look their best I don't
think they were actually lets you like
actually bought a bigger Instagram's
which is a
being he paid a lot to do that from I
mean you know I had a friend who was
doing that seek early when I found out
it was one of the reasons I kinda mad I
I was like this is
such a karate I was like this person is
such a broad your photoshopping your own
in I can't the but yes like online
dating see this said we're always a plan
their best selves and like her
perhaps a an altered way report
everything and also how to do what
celebrity magazines yet around that
seems normal to me that's kinda just
human nature versus like actually
the story summons for what they look
like nothing like themselves
and how this like perfect for me to
think this in in the world
by the way we have a tremendous amount
battling on the lens here so yeah that's
good for you
damn one rate right now yeah but tear
tear point when you started this whole
thing about congress
is there any chance congress like what
discourage have anything to do with this
like is this a type thing
complicate do anything they have like a
six percent approval rating they
literally can't pass a lot this point
nobody likes them
and this is what they're doing is that
store to the state America
summed up in a national yes and no I
actually this is what are the issues
what I'm sorry Mike well someone is
trying to do something that has actual
impact well this I feel like a law like
this
actually as much more impact on regular
America could have much more positive
impact on america
that a lot of work around the assets
that their job that that I have no faith
in them to
get anything done on this issue you have
its they're the worst
they're just or any final but that
congress I yeah I mean I don't think
they have any control over magazine
today I mean I know how this works out
there making a four-set
yeah I mean most likely they're just
gonna set industry guidelines right that
won't
that no no he raped many to change great
so good luck with your
industry guidelines people were or
up